[Music]
hey Colonel Brian here with another
edition of clueless gamer this is where
I rate videogames very ironic because I
don't really play them I'm not good at
them and I kind of hate them but who
better to review them than I today we
are tackling one of the biggies halo 4 I
have a little bit of a personal interest
in this because I recorded a voice for
Halo 4 I'm a character I don't know
where I don't know how I appear but
obviously that's gonna be the highlight
of the game
let's bring in my partner here this is
Aaron blare Aaron you work in which
department Oh Team Coco digital Team
Coco Digital okay we're gonna switch you
out of there soon like pregnant cars
tell me about halo 4 what do I need to
know to play this game it's the
beginning of a second trilogy in the
Halo universe basically there's this
alien race called the Covenant who is at
war with humanity who is actually having
a civil war itself between the inner and
outer colonies and the Covenant their
theocratic race quick question yes do
you have a girlfriend Daniel and they
worship a another ancient alien race
called the forerunners who perished in
battle with another alien race called
the flood who basically consumed all
flesh within the galaxy so why do you
know all of this I've been playing the
hey look it's that's what the game is
about you said a theocratic society
yeah the country even know what that is
it's AI think it's a religious if
they're based around religion wrong okay
it's a society built around the
character of Theo from The Cosby Show
anyway continue with your lecture
professor the Didact
you create a single decoder which
insurance he turned it against humanity
and but then he screwed up the enemies
to them oh there's these AI warriors
they're made of computer stuff basically
guys you see to you you just try to kill
them that just get what I've done that
over forty minutes ago
now we're gonna watch a quick prologue
of course this never used to happen when
I was coming along in the 80s there was
no prologue to pong you're gonna mean
they didn't tell you the story it was a
little bit blit it just happened okay
now this is us at the the back end of
the ship were in cryogenic slumber we're
just floating out in space and I'm
asleep you're asleep trying something
wow what an action-packed tale wait a
minute something's happening who's that
that's your artificial intelligence
companion Cortana seems like old times
she lives on a microchip that you put in
your helmet can she go anywhere on my
body or is she just standing she ever I
don't rip the South she updated your
firmware while you were asleep if she
did I thought you'd never ask
what you go you put her in your helmet
no she doesn't really exist this she's
sort of like Manti Te'o's girlfriend
I want to go scoping around there
godammit
my father watts stares lingerie third
floor okay so now basically an
artificial gravity well has pulled the
ship infinity which came to rescue us on
her planet Requiem and the Didact who
will be below confirm his ancient
slumber why is it like sleeping we slept
for four years and that was a Didac than
an ancient slumber sounds like it's
Planet ambien we're just napping all the
time
still they wake up and kill they make
time for another Salemme we're gonna
play co-op mode you're on top okay here
we go okay
now I'm just spinning around hey you
know what I'm panicking in battle and
just spinning in circles all right
you're trouble in the forest so now
we're gonna get in the tank there we go
there we go we go
all right so kind of go go right is that
like oh yeah you know what I'm doing
better in the tank than I did with just
my own body yeah when I was growing up
my parents had his large station wagon a
1970 Pontiac and that's what I learned
to drive on and this handles a lot like
a 1970 Pontiac look I'm waiting this guy
up and have some death want some death
have a death cookie my death cookie with
some blow-up milk some flan made of your
dead okay our tank got a little messed
up the good news is this is a rental
good news we're just gonna turn this
back in there Hertz and say I don't know
whose this way when I got it
what are we moving on to now you
disobeyed orders and decided not to hand
over Cortana so now you're going rogue
and you're gonna oh they wanted my sexy
girl yes and I didn't give her up
yes does she know that I didn't give her
up I think so I hope so that would be
money in the bank if you know what I
mean I take a girl for a ride oh my god
so now I thought we could move on to the
level where you're actually in I'm in
this is the level that I recorded the
noise for this is the level that you're
in you okay
that's us yeah that's me and Annie this
is a pretty sweet union we're in that's
fantastic
stand near the crates but don't ever
move them if anybody even looks at the
crates that's a violation absolutely
just like literally I'm not talking wall
to wall but like five area rugs
I'm talking about area rugs in their
sacred game can I shoot myself
you can elbow yourself to death I think
something's up what I think there's
gonna be a war with an alien they awoke
from a nation
I punch myself in the face I always
wanted to do that
Amy's running away sandy handy -
furniture it is hard to get he's fast
it's Wiley sleep tight Richter it was
more satisfying to punch knocked myself
out
that's my self-loathing at work alright
so how would you rate halo 4 halo 4 I
have to say fantastic graphics good god
that woman is absolutely gorgeous I'm
very attracted to that woman and almost
to the point of it being sad how do I
rate the game let's say I'll use noises
if I it's very good and it's very bad
I'm gonna give this up
that's my rating figure it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]